nous avions des bons soirs le monde
entier a soudain pris conscience de la
gravité de la situation jusqu'à présent
les chefs d'état joué à se faire peur et
les opinions publiques ne croyez pas
vraiment à la guerre en quelques heures
hier
tout a basculé l'échec des discussions
entre américains et irakiens genève a
semble-t-il traumatisé les dirigeants y
compris ceux qui étaient qui restent
déterminés par exemple george bush
sa première réaction l'illustrent il
semblait surtout atterré
brouillard et vitesse à l'origine d'un
carambolage monstre sur l'autoroute près
de thionville en moselle une centaine de
voitures sont en cause le bilan 53
blessés dont huit dans un état grave
après le meurtre d'un jeune homme à hier
à evry les experts de la violence
urbaine s'interroge sur l'évolution
inquiétante de ce phénomène en france
sommes-nous en passe de ressembler à
l'amérique journée nationale de
l'audition 7 millions de français
entendent mal sont toujours s'en rendre
compte et trop souvent lorsqu'ils
consultent il est déjà trop tard
les baskets tous les jeunes français
veulent tant porter ce n'est plus une
mode c'est devenu un véritable phénomène
économique des fabricants font assaut de
techniques d'originalité c'est notre
enquête de ce soir le prêt-à-porter de
l'hiver prochain défilent en ce moment à
paris du plus spectaculaire john
galliano plus abouti l'éternel yves
salon madame monsieur bonsoir brouillard
vitesse excessive chaussées glissantes
ou les ingrédients étaient
malheureusement réuni ce matin sur
l'autoroute a31 au sud de thionville en
moselle pour un carambolage monstre une
centaine de voitures et de camions sont
en cause le bilan 53 blessés dont huit
dans un état sérieux
une centaine de sapeurs pompiers
médecins gendarmes ont dû procéder toute
la matinée à des désincarcérations de
blessés coincés dans leurs véhicules et
un véritable hôpital de campagne a été
dressée sur place match et
nous ne sommes pas dans une casse mais
sur l'autoroute a31 chaussée couverte de
givre épais brouillard et vitesse
excessive ont eu raison de ses voitures
il est 7 heures du matin entre metz et
thionville forte circulation quand une
voiture se met en travers
c'était tellement vite
dans les trois cas de voitures étaient
alignés devant au travers moi j'ai
réussi à freiner un peu mais après ça
qu'on s'est tapé vers l'arrière par
contre totalement 8 attendu et cetera et
cetera au total une centaine de
véhicules s'entrechoquent pour ne plus
former qu'un amas de ferraille
pompiers gendarmes se mobilisent un
poste médical avancé s'installe pour
répartir des blessés au visage blême
aucun mort une soixantaine de blessés le
pronostic reste réservé pour deux
d'entre eux c'est un miracle compte tenu
surtout du fait qu'il ya pas utiliser
qui a vu en vue dans nos ressources se
transforme en catastrophe
l'autoroute coupée pendant cinq heures
n'a été réouverte qu'en début d'après
midi
d'après les témoins lundi
vite et n'était que de 50 mètres un
brouillard qui aurait dû amener certains
conducteurs à réduire leur vitesse
la france à l'unisson depuis le début de
l'après midi déjà les français célèbrent
cette finale de rêve cent mille
personnes sur les champs elysées le
visage pâle et drapeau tricolore à la
main et la fouille des supporteurs qui
accompagne le départ de l'équipe de
france de clairefontaine vers saint
denis
madame monsieur bonsoir l'événement
promet d'être unique pour cette dernière
coupe du monde du siècle peut être le
rêve à portée de main des tricolores
dans un instant nous retrouverons en
direct au stade de france nos équipes
mais aussi à marseille à lille à
clairefontaine toute la rédaction est
mobilisé en effet également dans un
instant dans ce journal avec nos
reporter à rio mais d'abord cette fièvre
immense sur la place de l'hôtel de ville
l'équipe de france réclame elle le
soutient les supporteurs elle a été
entendue avant même le début du match
puisque dès cet après midi sur les
champs elysées par milliers ils ont
convergé vers la place de l'étoile
dans une ambiance de fête que les plus
anciens comparé à la liesse de la
libération au point molly vielles caroff
à l'usb tulard sur les champs elysées
en réalité une fête énorme
un coup de foudre entre la france et le
brésil
tout l'après midi des dizaines de
milliers de supporters des deux équipes
se sont retrouvées parfois dans la même
voiture
les jaune et vert mélangé au bleu blanc
rouge
difficile de savoir qui soutient la
france et qui souhaitent une nouvelle
victoire brésilienne un grand mélange
des couleurs même si pour les cadeaux
souvenirs c'est clair
l'équipe de ronaldo est absolument
imbattable s'était pas les matchs
jouer l'abri en avait vendu combien d
une ferveur qui a de quoi impressionner
les plus blasés des cariocas
je sais comme moi carnaval c'est un
carnaval
hori oka il avait totalement cet après
midi peu importe et finalement le
pronostic l'âge ou le mode de locomotion
l'important c'était d'être de la partie
klaxons contre samba match nul devant
les écrans géants installés dans la
capitale
quel que soit le score final dans moins
de trois aires ses supporters l'ont déjà
gagné
jacques yves cousteau est mort mercredi
à paris il était dans sa 88e année cet
homme maître par le matériel et par
l'image de l'exploration des océans fait
figure de héros pour les français c'est
aussi une star à l'étranger le
commandant avait également su avec plus
ou moins de réussite bâtir un empire
contesté par certains scientifiques mais
académiciens mais palme d'or à cannes en
1956 pour le monde du silence dans l'
aventure cousteau il y à la calypso ou
jojo le mérou cousteau disait le
plongeur s'ils cessent de nager reste
entre deux eaux comme un archange
invités de ce journal madame cousteau et
le docteur jean louis etienne parmi les
autres titres de l'actualité collision
dans l'espace entre la station orbitale
mir et le vaisseau de ravitaillement
l'équipage est sauf le possible report
du procès papon pour raisons budgétaires
enfin la réforme aubry sur les
licenciements
le ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité veut plus de sécurité
juridique et moins de précarité pour les
salariés
madame monsieur bonsoir un destin au
coin de la route
à sa sortie de l'école navale dans le
milieu des années trente cousteau pense
à une carrière dans l'aviation
mais il un accident de voiture et sa
rééducation passe par la natation de la
l'épopée qui va suivre
josé dans la pierre
l'accident sur l' enquête son accident
de lady diana le chauffeur de la voiture
conduisait en état d'ébriété alors que
l'on se retrouve toujours beaucoup de
questions sur les circonstances exactes
de ce drame
dans ce journal nous entendrons un
témoignage capital celui d'un médecin
qui a apporté les tout premiers soins
aux victimes
les obsèques de la princesse de galles
auront lieu samedi matin à l'abbaye de
wesminster des obsèques quasi nationale
dans ce journal nous reviendrons
également sur le débat lancé sur
l'attitude des paparazzi avec le
témoignage de deux stars qui ont eu à
souffrir des moeurs d'une certaine
presse à scandale sandrine bonnaire et
william porte dans soir nous vous
retrouvons dans un instant madame
monsieur madame monsieur bonsoir les
suites de l'enquêté sur les
circonstances de l'accident qui a coûté
la vie à la princesse diana son
compagnon et le chauffeur de la voiture
l'homme qui sans doute le mieux
renseignés de france le ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement l'a
lui même précisé
il convient d'être très prudent seul
élément véritablement nouveau
aujourd'hui dans un flot de rumeurs et
de témoignages contradictoires
le chauffeur de la voiture conduisait en
état d'ébriété avec un taux de 1 g 75
alcool ce qui représente un risque
d'accident x 35 tout de suite le point
de l'enquète valérie ermite michel
giannoulas tous
la mercedes 280 rouler très vite trop
vite
plus de 150 kilomètres heures selon
certains témoins le compteur lui se
serait bloqué aux alentours des 200
kilomètres heure mais les spécialistes
n'en tirait pour l'instant aucune
conclusion définitive il faudra attendre
la fin des expertises
l'élément nouveau lui est parvenue du
parquet de paris cet après midi
henri-paul le chauffeur qui travaillait
au ritz conduisait en état d'ébriété un
gramme 75 d'alcool dans le sang
au lieu des 0,5 toléré par la
législation française
le chauffeur aurait-il alors perdu tout
seul le contrôle de sa voiture
ou encore comme l'expliquent un témoin à
l'avocat de la famille al-fayed
aurait-il été gêné par un motard qui
zigzaguait devant lui il a pensé qu'il
s'agissait
un cortège officiel et puis à pénétrant
dans le tunnel de l'alma
il a ensuite vu une moto qui se trouvait
devant le véhicule mercedes et qui
semblait hees tenté d'empêcher sa
progression seul trait vori jones garde
du corps de lady diana unique survivant
de l'accident pourrait confirmer ou non
cette hypothèse
une hypothèse que les enquêteurs
jugerait cependant peu probable
l'implication directe dans l'accident
des paparazzi pourrait même être écarté
leurs motos se serait trouvé au moins à
100 m derrière la voiture
reste alors la polémique sur l'attitude
des photographes
après l'accident des photographes une
main anonyme a déjà désigné comme
coupable
c'était moins un américain arrivé avant
les secours ont effectivement vu des
photographes autour de la voiture mais
il ne parle pas de gêne particulière
oui on a vu des photographes et qu'est
ce qu'il faisait mais il traînait autour
de la watch valley rouge peut pas dire
que j'en ai vu un prendre des photos
mais il était dans le coin
d'autres en revanche affirmé avoir vu
mitraillé la voiture les paparazzis
aurait-il continuer à prendre des photos
sans avoir essayé de porter secours
c'est sur cette notion de non assistance
à personne en danger qu'il pourrait être
poursuivi